I was just listening to your stats which  are unbelievably incredible you were the  only quarterback who has beaten both the  Patriots and the Falcons those are the  two teams in this Super Bowl you were in  a unique position to call what might  happen on Sunday what do you think it's  gonna be you know two two great teams  obviously obviously Tom Brady being one  of the greatest quarterbacks of all time  and then obviously Matt Ryan's had an  unbelievable year this year I've done so  many great things though you know it's  gonna be tough to cover Julio Jones  Mohamed Sanu and yeah yeah Vontae  Freeman I think I'm going with it  with the or the Patriots are you go with  Patriots okay okay they've won before  they've been there so they've been there  many times so they'll be calmer they'll  be they'll be used to it all right  you